verado en la sala de los mahi tennis
sector cordillera know della provincia
de culture su objetivo rescatar a los
ojos sobre de dientes ko UN / malicia en
el lado vistas desde el cielo los restos
de l'opera to do gallo presentar una
decisión de sol adoro inter ribbon RS
increible que vc sighs persona Judy
Ranveer y con villain Antony no speedo
ambiente y más incredible la forma en
que dos de los muchachos pudieron
escapar de saber nadera prigioni yellow
n clavado en el corazon de los andes
this is the real plane the focal fetch
fetch i love the Lion Air Force number
571 that was half of that was my home
for 72 days it was under other mother
and playing for that time he that cross
the unders many times it was necessary
no it was not necessary an unsafe flight
what we were going to have and this is
the plane after the crash this photo was
taken by the rescuers and this is how
they play looked before we after we left
our home in the mountains and this is
the view of where we were of the glacier
where we were this photo was taken also
after we left the mountains but this one
was was taken by ourselves this was the
real view that we had from or from the
from the plane and you see that we
didn't really know where we were if we
really walk in that direction there was
a horrible mountain at the end of the
valley that actually the sauce yellow
mountain of course we didn't know its
name at that time and this is how we
spend most of the time you see
sunbathing
ah we were we were we were so in a bleak
a big sip sleeping bag with an
insulating material that we took out
from the tail of the plane we didn't
know how many nights of friends were
going to spend in the open air and and
this is how we highways how we spend
time I'm the one who is sitting on top
of the fuselage this is also some time
over there you see some fleshless human
rest around we're licked really like
small hungry animals living in on the in
the plane this is an hour photo of
ourselves over there you see that we had
some friendship going on we have jokes
with spend some good time we we love
each other with we also have a lot of
laughing at sometimes I don't remember
the jokes but I do remember the laughing
this is another picture of ourselves
over there on the end well are there at
the end the time the weather happy
proved very much we also had some warm
one day's over there this is the last
light night at a group of us spent in
the mountain I was not there I had
already left the mountain de Sade guys
paint seventy three nights in the
mountains and not 72 and this is the
very well-known picture that was taken
by helicopters when they arrived to
rescue us and this is their memorial
that was built by the relatives of her
friends who in order of those who didn't
come back
well I want to finish my presentation
telling you that that in a way where
were little more than teenagers when we
boarded that plane on October 13th of
1972 and when we got out of the mountain
on the summer the 22nd we were basically
very primitive and rude man just 72 days
later men that had lived an ordeal been
dad didn't talk much when that thought
simple things men that had learned that
in order to survive we just had to live
one more day we all knew that we had to
make it as a team otherwise we would not
have made it the fact is that nobody
tried to escape in search of individual
survival and we all work for the team
because we knew it was the best thing
that we can do in order to survive as a
group and as individuals